[Music]
welcome back to our own box today I am
finally able to review Amy's answer to
in videos recently released GeForce GTX
1650s super code names now b14 we
finally have the radio rx 5500 XT on
hand and while this is technically a day
one review it's not the first 5500
exterior review to hit the net some
lucky reviewers managed to get their
hands and OAM versions which allowed
them to test ahead of time or at least
ahead of today's AIB release where we
can test models from gigabyte and MSI
and their initial results weren't great
but of course without any solid pricing
information it was hard to gauge just
how good or bad
Navi 14 would be in terms of value and
that's what we plan to work out today
but before we get too far into today's
review today's video is sponsored by
gigabyte in this special interview offer
for Australian and New Zealand customers
right now if you buy any gigabyte X 570
motherboard with a risin 7 or riser 9
CPU you'll be eligible for a free
gigabyte Gen 4 500 gigabyte SSD valued
at 250 dollars
alternatively if you purchase a gigabyte
radeon RX 5700 XD graphics card you'll
receive a bonus gigabyte m2 nvme 512
gigabyte SSD valued at 120 dollars so
for more information to please check the
link in the video description ok so on
hand today to evaluate just how good the
5500 XT is we have two new AIB models on
hand for testing we have one from MSI
and one from gigabyte MSI sent over
their gaming X model and a gigabyte
their gaming AC version and I have to
say both do look very nice now Before we
jump into the benchmarks let's just
quickly talk about the 5500 XT the tiny
158 millimeter square die packs just
1408 cores and 88 texture units almost
40% fewer than the rx 570 there's also
half as many ROPS and this has reduced
the memory bus from 256 bit down to just
128 bit wide which sees the memory
bandwidth half to two hundred and twenty
four gigabytes per second still AMD is
using G DDR six
memory and you can purchase the 5500 XT
with either 4 or 8 gigabytes of vram I
have the 4 gigabyte model on hand but I
won't be featuring it in this video
rather I'll be providing a detailed 4
vs. 8 gigabyte comparison soon for now
the focus is on the a gigabyte version
but getting back to the course for a
moment they're clocked at 1600 and 70
megahertz for the base and 1845
megahertz for the boost which means
their clock 7 percent higher than the
5700 calls however because there is a
lot less of them the TDP has been
reduced from 180 watts down to 150 watts
now there is a really no delicate way of
putting this so I'm just gonna say it
the 8 gigabyte version of the 5500 XT
comes in at an MSRP of $200 u.s. and
frankly that seems like a lot given the
specs the 4 gigabyte model that'll set
you back a hundred and seventy dollars
and again that seems like a lot of money
for a 4 gigabyte graphics card in very
late 2019 anyway we'll review the price
to performance offered by the 5500 XT
towards the end of the video for now
let's just check out the test system
specs and then get into the benchmarks
the test system used includes a kora 9
1900 collector 5 gigahertz with 16
gigabytes of ddr4 3400 memory and the
exact graphics card models used for
testing can be found in the video
description though please note the
gigabyte rx 5500 XT gaming OC was used
exclusively for all the 5500 XE testing
in this video finally we have 12 games
to look at and all have been tested at
tourney P and 1440p using medium to high
quality presets or settings so let's get
into the results first up we have shut
off the Tomb Raider and with the higher
quality preset enable at changi P the
5500 XT was good for 77 fps an average
not bad performance but not great either
given the rx 590 was a little faster and
the 1660 Super was almost 20% faster
even at 1440p we see much the same and
despite the extra vrm the 5,500 xt can't
gain on the 1660 super here here we see
the 5500 xt does manage to edge out the
RX 590
Assassin's Creed Odyssey with an average
of 71 fps making it four percent faster
or a mere three FPS the 1660 super was
11% faster though the 5,500 xt was 8%
faster than the 1650 super moving to
1440p and we see very similar margins
the 5,500 xt is still on par with the
gtx 1660 which also puts a vampire with
the RX 590 and gtx 1650 super so not a
great result here for AMD's new $200
u.s. offering using the higher quality
settings in Red Dead Redemption 2 may
have been a mistake with these Lara and
GPUs as frame rates are quite low even
at 1080p also please note the 3 gigabyte
1060 didn't work as the texture settings
were too high and you can't override
memory restrictions in this title so
rather than give the 3 gigabyte 1060 an
advantage with the medium quality
texture setting I just opted to skip it
for this one performance at 1080p for
the 5500 XT is pretty disappointing it
only matched the RX 580 and the gtx 1650
super and that things weren't much
better at 1440p using the higher quality
settings the game wasn't really playable
so you'll need to drop down to medium if
you hope to play at this resolution with
anything less than an Rx 5700 or r-tx
2060 the 5500 XT did deliver a
silky-smooth 106 FPS on average at 1080p
in World of Tanks
but that really was only enough to see
it positioned as a mid field runner in
our testing only matching the 3 gigabyte
1060 though it did put it on par with
the rx 590 but still a pretty unexcited
result the 1440p results weren't much
better here it's a fraction slower than
the rx 590 and really no better than the
much cheaper GTX 1650 super performance
in Far Cry nude on is typical of what
we've seen so far the 5500 XT is a
smidgen quicker than the 590 and just 6%
faster than the 1650s super which
frankly is a pretty miserable result for
AMD
given they want to charge $200 for this
thing not much difference at 1440p
the 5500 XT and 590 are neck-and-neck
while the 1660 supe is well out in front
delivering nearly 20% more performance
which isn't great for AMD given Nvidia
are only charging 15% more here we see
that frame rates in Rainbow six siege
are strong at 1080p using the very
higher quality preset which is one notch
down from ultra though we are manually
cranking the render scale back up to
100% the 5500 XT was still slower than
the rx 590 and really not a great deal
faster than the much cheaper 1650 super
much the same as seen we're testing at
1440p the 5500 xt only manages to keep
pace with the gtx 1650 super and rx 580
here we see that the Star Wars Jedi
full-on order performance at 1080p is
pretty average here the 5500 XT is
slower than the GTX 1650 super and the
old GTX 1666 Giga Byte basically it
finds itself situated between the 590
and the 580 moving to 1440p allows the
5500 xtina match the 1650 super and 3
gigabyte 1060 so yeah not a particularly
great result here either
using the higher quality preset at 1080p
in battlefield 5 allowed the 5500 XC to
average 83 fps in our tests which sadly
meant it was only able to match the RX
580 and render just 3 FPS more than the
1650 super on average here we see though
that the more limited 4 gigabyte vram
buffer does appear to hurt the 1650
super at 1440p and now the 5500 xt is
able to deliver 13% more performance
with 62 FPS on average but given it cost
25% more I wouldn't go getting too
excited about this news the call of duty
modern warfare results are very similar
to what we've seen so far the 5500 XT is
basically on par with the RX 590 and GTX
1650 super even at 1440p the 5500 xt
can't get away from the 1650 super and
it even manages to slip behind the RX
590 so again not a great result here
Metro Exodus was tested with the ultra
quality preset enabled as the 5500 XT
and equivalent NVIDIA GPUs averaged over
60 fps attorney P the 5500 XT came in
behind the rx 580 so not exactly a
stellar result
it was also 10% slower than the rx 590
moving up to 1440 piece or the 5500 XT
dropped down to an average of 51 FPS
which again meant it was a few frames
slower than the rx 580 though at least
in this tile it was quite a bit fast in
the GTX 1650 super especially when
looking at the 1% low performance here
we see that the 5500 XT once again
trails the RX 580 this time in f1 2019
at 1080p using the higher quality preset
granted 121 FPS on average is pretty
great gaming performance and still less
than what you get with a 5 8590 GTX 60
and 60 or 1660 super the 5500 xt does
match the 580 at 1440p making at 5 to 6
FPS sold in the 590 and 11% slower than
the 1660 super last up we have gears 5
and here the 5500 XT is able to match
the RX 590 was 75 FPS on average at
1080p using the higher quality preset
here we also see that the 1660 super is
14% faster and given that it cost 15%
more it looks like AMD's just slotted
into in videos current pricing scheme
rather than compete with it here's a
quick look at total system power
consumption in Gears v + f1 2019 as you
can see the 5500 xt is a big improvement
on the 580 and 590 reducing total system
consumption by around 30% the 1660 super
still used slightly less power but at
this point I feel it's a bit of a
non-issue overall power consumption is
good not amazing for a seven nanometer
GPU but it's comparable to where Nvidia
are at right now well I've got to say
given the price the eight gigabyte 5500
XT didn't look too hot in any of those
benchmarks but Before we jump into the
cost per frame analysis let's just look
at the average performance across the
dozen games tested at 1080p and 1440p
no surprises here on average the 5500 XT
was indeed slower than the rx 590 and
only three and a half percent faster
than the rx 580
moreover it was just 5% faster than the
GTX 1650 super and 13% slower than the
GTX 1660 super the results at the 1440p
solution are much the same it's again a
whisker faster than the 580 and slightly
slower than the 590 so let's move on to
check out the cost per frame data okay
well as expected this doesn't look
particularly great basically the Radeon
rx 5500 xt 8 gigabyte comes in offering
the same level of value as the gtx 1660
super at $2 27 per frame based on our 12
game sample that means you'll be paying
a 4% premium per frame over the RX 590
at the current prices were still the
5500 XT comes in at almost 20 percent
more per frame than the gtx 1650 super
and we are really talking about a
similar level of performance here
granted the 8 gigabyte 5500 XT does pack
twice as much of erm but still not a
good result for AMD and those seeking a
budget graphics card it's also worth
noting that the 8 gigabyte 5500 XT costs
around 14% more per frame when compared
to existing a gigabyte rx5 80s so not
exactly progress that is it but what
about the cheaper 4 gigabyte version
that I'm yet to test
juda time constraints well AMD says with
medium to high quality settings at 1080p
a 4 gigabyte model is around 5% slower
on average so that would place it on
power to GTX 1650 super in terms of
performance but let's just say the
performance goes unchanged so we'll
stick with 88 FPS on average an absolute
best case scenario for sure what this
means is aimed II can't beat the GTX
1650 Super when asking a hundred and
seventy dollars us for the 4 gigabyte
version of the 5500 XT they just can't
win that battle moreover for the same
money I think I'd rather own an RX 580
and get twice as much vram again how is
this progress AMD I'll just note again
that I will be testing the 4 gigabyte
model over the next few days so expect a
detailed full gigabyte versus a gigabyte
analysis soon but I can't see us ending
up with a good result for AMD here well
I've got to say that was massively
disappointing and the performance isn't
the real issue here the 5500 X
was never going to blow your socks off
the issue is the price Andy's just made
no attempt to undercut Nvidia they've
just slaughtered the 5,500 XT into
Nvidia's existing pricing structure so
essentially they've rocked up to the
party late and offered us nothing new
it's a little crazy to think they were
selling us a two hundred and thirty two
millimeters squared die for $200 or less
and they've been doing so for a little
over a year now and then we finally get
an update that's considerably smaller at
158 millimeters squared so 32% smaller
and it offers the same level of
performance and cost just as much no
doubt 7nm air supply is playing a big
role in that price but I doubt many of
you watching this review care about that
it's more of an AMD problem but whatever
the case it looks like a MIDI may have
shot themselves in the foot here by
aggressively competing with
three-year-old Polaris GPUs that
ultimately they did have to do this in
order to remain competitive in one of
the few GPU price segments they're
actually competing in and this all
started with the RX 4 ad back in June of
2016 at a price of 240 dollars u.s. for
the 8 gigabyte model a year later it was
refreshed as the RX 580 and a $10
discount and by late 2018 was retailing
for under $200 then as I said a moment
ago for about the last 12 months or so
they could easily be found for just a
hundred and seventy dollars and that's a
30% discount on where this silly can
began three years ago now but aim DS own
products aside for a moment the 5500 xt
struggles to compete with what nvidia is
already offering in the 1650 super and
1660 super therefore I see no reason to
wait for 5500 stock to arrive and then
try and hunt one down at the MSRP
there's plenty of 1650 super and 1660
super graphics cards selling at or very
near the MSRP so I just grabbed one of
those or alternatively snag a cheap rx
580 power consumption of the 5500 XT has
been greatly improved over the rx 580
but the gamers really care about that
it's not like you can't easily power the
580 or 590 with a cheap 400 watt power
supply and after all remember the power
consumption results shown here in this
review were
recorded in our overclocked quarry 999
hundred K test system so expect total
system power usage to be considerably
lower with a core i5 or Rison v
processor so while lower power
consumption is certainly a nice bonus
and should result in cooler and quieter
graphics cards I feel most gamers
looking at spending $200 or less on a
graphics card really just care about
price to performance and here the 5500
XT offers nothing new if anything it's a
small step backwards and finally just a
quick side note regarding Amy's new
Radeon software features found in the
adrenaline 2020 Edition they're
impressive and AMD should be commended
for their work here adding features such
as integer scaling for all radeon gpus
at least those based on the GCN
architecture and newer is impressive and
radio and boost looks interesting though
I doubt I'd use it but still a nice
option to have and I'm sure some gamers
will find it useful
anyway wrapping this up the 5500 XT is a
very disappointing release in my opinion
I just hope AMD get a bit more
aggressive on pricing over the next few
months so fingers crossed that happens
and that's really all we can do at this
point and that is going to do it for
this review if you enjoyed the video be
sure to LIKE subscribe do that.you to be
stuff and if you'd like to get more
involved with the channel and support
harbor unbox directly then consider
jumping over to our patreon page there's
a few different tiers there you get
access to our monthly live stream so you
can live chat with us there we've also
got a discord chat which you can chat
with us there and we also offer merch if
you want to support us in a different
way and get some cool clothes and other
items mugs and things so we have the
limited edition happy unboxing sweater
so ourselves use call these jumpers but
yeah sweaters elsewhere we also have
t-shirts and then we have some cool
hoodies and other things as well so if
you're interested in that link is in the
video description but above all else
thank you for watching I'm your host
Steve and I'll see you again next time
[Music]
you